[Music]
on this Wednesday night collateral
damage civilians in Gaza caught in the
crossfire we were busted about this
Canadian man's heartache his message to
the federal government as gaza's
hospitals run out of fuel and Medicine a
detailed account of how Hamas carried
out its attack they went house by house
and they just shot shoot to kill and how
armed civilians fought back hurrian Kan
Otis the menacing storm mowing through a
part of Mexico and Reviving some Visa
Services a promising sign in India and
Canada's tense
relationship global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us as Israel's Siege on Gaza
enters its 19th night the crisis there
is worsening each air strike flattens
more neighborhoods and Israel has
dropped thousands of bombs there Hamas
started this war Israel's government
intends to finish it for civilians
including women and children and foreign
Nationals There Is No Escape gaza's
Health Ministry run by Hamas says more
than 6,500 people in Gaza have been
killed more than 177,000 wounded 12 of
gaza's 35 hospitals are not functioning
that's according to the World Health
Organization today the American
president said again Hamas does not
represent all Palestinians that
civilians must be protected and there
must be a vision for the
future Israelis and Palestinians equally
deserve to live side by side in safety
dignity and peace there's no going back
to the status quo as it stood on October
the
6th right now no one is talking peace
and people in Gaza don't know if they'll
survive another night we have complete
coverage tonight Jeff SLE is in
Jerusalem with an account of how Hamas
attacked one Israeli community and
Danielle Hamin our new correspondent
begins our coverage with the situation
in Gaza Danielle Donna the United
Nations had warned that by Wednesday
night fuel supplies were going to run
out across Gaza and tonight there are no
signs any fuel is making its way into
the territory Israel says it doesn't
Target
civilians but it is killing them by the
thousands the Israeli military believes
the homes of Hamas militants are
legitimate targets even if civilians
live alongside them and says it has
eliminated senior Hamas
leaders entire fames wiped out people
who did not die of of of bombart they
will
die lack of
medicines local journalists working with
global news went into alifa Hospital in
Northern
Gaza this is how much medicine is left
the fuel supply is even
worse needed to purify water fuel is
also what keeps the hospital generators
running no working generators means no
electricity Israel claims Hamas is
stockpiling hundreds of thousands of
leaders among those trapped in these
scenes of Carnage is Samir s Alam from
1947 they pushed us out of our country a
Canadian man who lost five members of
his family I am asking my government
Canadian government to take a
responsibility to support even if they
are not supporting Palestinians to
support their own Canadian citizen they
were killed after an Israeli strike in
the south of Gaza where the Israeli
government told them it would be
safer their names were sha hany Sarah
Huda and
Omar this is every moment of every day
here young girl who looks for her mother
and miraculously finds
her and a father who has yet to find his
daughter with each hour that goes by
there's a sense that death will come
before any help from the outside world
so is there a death toll that is too
high for Canada a red line it's a
question I put to a senior Canadian
Diplomat and I'm told Donna that there
isn't a number but rather it's a
question of criminal indifference and
intentional disregard for human life and
Canada does not think Israel has crossed
that line yet Donna Danielle hamam Jim
in Jerusalem thanks Israel is refusing
visas for all un representatives and
demanding United Nations Secretary
General Antonio gutes resigned yesterday
he condemned unequivocally the deadly
attacks on Israel by Hamas two weeks ago
but said they did not happen in a vacuum
he said that Palestinians have been
subjected to 56 6 years of suffocating
occupation Israel's ambassador to the UN
accused him of justifying terrorism
today guttera said he needed to set the
record straight I am shocked by the
misrepresentations by some of my
statement yesterday in the security
Council as
if as if I was justifying acts of Terror
by
amas this is false
it was the opposite gutterz has also
accused Israel of clear violations of
humanitarian law in Gaza and insisted a
humanitarian ceasefire is vital Israel's
prime minister gave a televised address
tonight telling his country a ground
Invasion into Gaza is coming it will he
said both destroy Hamas and bring the
hostages home and for the first time
Benjamin Netanyahu acknowledged he is
accountable for the security failures on
October
7th It's s
everyone H will have to provide answers
about that failure he said including
myself it was the worst attack on
civilians in Israel's history and
details of how it happened are still
emerging here's Jeff
sble just after Dawn on October 7th
these Hamas militants wearing body
cameras took off from Gaza on
motorcycles loaded with weapons their
target the small Israeli community of
sufa home to around 50
families as they approached they came
under Fire from a small Israeli military
post the battle didn't last
long the explosions could be heard a
kilometer away in the community of sufa
something sound very very strange very
loud very massive jual balison took his
pregnant wife and toddler to their safe
room he started receiving messages from
Neighbors who said he was needed to go
out and fight his wife urged him not to
I was afraid tell you the truth I was
afraid because I didn't know what
happened
outside the gunman entered the kots and
started shooting homes an
ambulance even this dog tamaria Coen was
the dog's owner they went house by house
and they just shut
shoot shoot to
kill that bullet went through the front
door and killed Bernard Cohen the
57-year-old married father an unarmed
civilian then the militants started
searching
inside setting fires and shooting
indiscriminately and Z come down he
shouts in Arabic it was really
frightening this resident her daughter
and two young granddaughters were hiding
in the the safe room trying to stay
quiet hell came to visit us what is
going on where's the Army where's the
country where
is I we felt like we were abandoned
after waiting an hour with no sign of
the Israeli military bisan decided to go
and fight like most Israelis he has
military training but works as a civil
engineer he was one of only four
residents with a rifle going up against
around 30 Hamas militants that's my duty
if I have a gun that is my duty from
behind a concrete wall the Israelis
opened fire the militants scattered and
bison went up on the roof of his
parents' house it was a a very good
position they held off the Hamas
attackers for 5 hours until the Israeli
military finally
arrived when the fighting ended three
local israelies were dead along with at
least 15 Hamas Fighters why do you think
you were able to be so successful
uccessful against them I have no idea I
just go to defend my kibuts the family
it's still too dangerous for bison's
family to return to their home but
unlike many other Israeli communities
they still have a home to return
to Donna Jeff simple in Jerusalem thanks
in the US a new speaker of the house has
finally been elected Congressman Mike
Johnson a republican from Louisiana will
take the
gavl the next speak the people's house
Mike
John he is a staunch conservative and
vows to restore the people's faith in
the house for almost a month infighting
within the Republican party has
paralyzed the house one of the most
powerful storms to ever hit Mexico
roared ashore early this morning on the
beach resort of aapco as a category 5
hurricane it brought torrential rain and
Winds of up to 170 km an hour NE Gara on
the damage hurricane Otis is doing
the Mexican Coastal Community of
Acapulco took a direct hit from what
forecasters call a catastrophic
storm torrential rain and high winds
pummeled the Southern Pacific Coast
battering hotels and sending tourists
running for
cover the Mexican president said there
were no immediate reports of fatalities
but cautioned authorities were
struggling to get
updates hurricane otus explosively
strengthened in just a few hours
meteorologist say it set a record for
the fastest a hurricane has ever
intensified and they say somehow the
hurricane models missed it entirely
calling it an almost incomprehensible
Miss hurricane notis joins a growing
list of hurricanes that have intensified
rapidly right up until landfall and that
is a troubling sign that may partially
be due to climate change State officials
report heavy rains from the hurricane
caused landslides which forc the closure
of Acapulco Highway with no alternate
route not having connectivity is
definitely stressful for us Ryan mckern
is with a Canadian mining group with 25
delegates in Acapulco for one of the
country's largest mining trade shows the
group was evacuated from the hotel
shortly before losing phone and internet
connection we were very shocked uh about
uh how fast it happened it was very
unnerving to see and um and to lose
contact with our with our delegation
down there the conselor agency of Canada
temporarily Clos because of the
hurricane in the aftermath of what's
weakened to a tropical storm Nea Global
News there is a bit of a thaw in
Canada's relationship with India India's
High commission says it will resume
processing some Visa services for a
Canadian starting tomorrow after what it
calls a considered review of the
security situation the high commission
says it will process business medical
and Conference visas as well as entry
for people with family ties in India in
officials in Canada suspended Visa
Services about a month ago after prime
minister Justin Trudeau said the Indian
government may have been involved in the
killing of a sick leader in
BC I want to remind Canadians and
everybody um that there was a Canadian
that's killed on Canadian soil and we've
been asking for greater cooperation with
the
investigation when asked about the
investigation Sergeant cited the
independence of police in BC he said he
has confidence in their ability people
in a Northwest West Ontario City are
feeling the weight of what police call a
tragic case of intimate partner violence
the bodies of five people including
three children were found after
shootings at two separate homes
neighbors have been speaking with
shalima Maharaj today in s St Marie
Ontario shalima the police tape remains
up outside this home where the three
children were found inside fatally shot
the gunman also found inside from an
apparent self-inflicted gunshot wound
now this tragedy has has completely
shocked and saddened the community of
Sous St Marie some even feeling anger we
don't see this level of of of of
insanity you know this this is off the
charts Robert Le's home backs on to a
crime scene it's here that a 41-year-old
woman was found fatally shot Monday
evening multiple neighbors tell Global
News a woman and a Child live here I
didn't see this coming from him because
I didn't think he was that type of guy
this man lives nearby and says he knew
the gunman you can see sorry for your
condolence you can see whatever but it's
not helping them bring them
back those kids didn't deserve what
happened to them police have since
seized two Firearms inside the home
where three children were killed outside
toys can still be seen in the driveway
police say the tragedy was the result of
intimate partner violence what people
don't often know is that intimate
partner violence accounts for about
onethird of the violent crime crime that
police respond to and on Wednesday
police revealed the gunman had been
involved in intimate partner
investigations in the past it accounts
for one in eight solved homicides it's
one of the most common reasons that
children are referred to Child
Protective Services police are not yet
confirming the relationship between the
gunmen and the victims they still have
plenty of work left to do investigating
both of these seeds Donna shalim raah
haraj in s St Marie Ontario thanks in
Quebec a coroner is taking the police to
task for how the force handled the case
of two missing girls 3 years ago the
coroner says police failed to fully
grasp the urgency of the situation the
bodies of those girls and their father
who had killed them weren't found for
days Mike Armstrong explains what the
coroner says went
wrong we expect better that's coroner
Luke malo's conclusion criticizing
Provincial Police for how it handled The
Disappearance and search for Rami and
Nora Kier the two girls and their father
went missing after a small car accident
on a highway in July of 2020 what should
have been a massive search from the
get-go the coroner says took too long to
start and was too slow to ramp up could
the girls have been found alive M says
we'll never
know but we could have maximized their
chances he
says according to Witnesses at the
inquest had become a obsessed that his
estranged wife might get full custody of
their daughters the corner says the car
crash may have been a Tipping Point the
girl's bodies weren't found for 3 Days
kpan wasn't found for 12 the corner says
police made mistakes in planning the
search in Communications and sufficient
qualified Searchers weren't called in
early
enough now the girl's mother says the
coroner's report confirms what she's
felt since the beginning that police
didn't do everything they could have
Emily is looking at suing the provincial
police force her lawyers are in
negotiations right now and she says she
apologizes to her daughters every night
that they were in her words abandoned by
Society Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal an accused sexual predator on
the stand coming up disgraced former
fashion Mogul Peter nyard testifies at
his sex assault
trial 3 years after he was first
arrested in Winnipeg Peter nyard is
taking the stand in his own defense he
is accused of using his position in the
fashion industry to lure girls in women
he's on trial in Toronto charged with
five counts of sexual assault and one
count of forcible confinement Mike dray
on what happened in court clad in a
black blazer white shirt and dark
glasses former fashion Mogul Peter nyard
cut a calm demeanor as he testified in
his own defense the 82-year-old
described himself as a workaholic who
avoided drugs and alcohol and traveled
constantly for work his lawyer Brian
Greenspan told the jury ahead of
nygard's testimony that he will offer a
clear unequivocal and emphatic denial of
the sexual assaults and that it is
impossible to have a recollection of an
event that did not occur nyard he says
doesn't even remember ever meeting four
of the five women the alleged assaults
happened between the mid 1980s and mid
2000s with all five accusers claiming
they were allured to the top floor
bedroom suite of his Toronto offices
under the pretense of a tour or job
interview one of the complainants
testified the more I struggled the
angrier he got he was like an ogre a
really angry ogre why didn't you leave
asked the crown there was nowhere to go
there was no door handle she responded
that niggard said is true a key code was
needed to enter and a button was needed
to leave the Toronto trial is just the
beginning of nygard's legal fight after
he faces is another accuser in Quebec in
2024 he'll be extradited to the US where
he faces even more charges Mike trle
Global News
Toronto hungry and in need ahead the
concerning rise in food in security
across
Canada the latest report by food banks
Canada paints a dire picture in March it
says there were more than 1.9 million
visits to food Banks across Canada that
is a 32% increase from March of 2022
over 30% of food bank clients it says
are children even though they represent
20% of the
population behind each one of those
numbers are real people so the depth
of you know suffering across the country
the number of people who've hit a
Breaking Point and are turning to their
communities for support it's just it's
overwhelming to think of that replicate
it right across the country the cost of
food and housing plus low wages were the
main reasons people said they went to
Food Banks this year there is no change
in interest rates the Bank of Canada has
held its key interest rate steady at 5%
today that was expected by economists
after inflation eased to 3.8% in
September that's still higher though
than the bank of Canada's Target
inflation rate of about 2% Bank of
Canada Governor Tiff mlam said today the
Israel Hamas conflict could impact the
global
economy in a more hostile World Energy
prices could move up sharply Supply
chains could become disrupted again and
all of that could push up inflation
again around the world further rate
hikes he says are not off the table
maclam says they're prepared to raise
rates again if inflation numbers don't
continue to come
down bring them home next to musical
plea from the Israeli
Opera
today is World Opera day which is not
normally something we'd put on the news
but the Israeli Opera is marking the day
with a powerful tribute to the hostages
held by Hamas in
[Music]
[Applause]
Gaza it is a version of bring him home
from L miserab both these soloists no
family and friends caught in the attacks
20 children are among the more than 200
people held hostage Israel says the
Israeli Opera is asking Opera Houses
around the world to share this recording
music it says has a way of reaching
people deeply that is global national
for this Wednesday thanks for
[Music]
watching